hey leute und willkommen zu einer
texture pack vorstellung von dem echelon
texture pack von rätsel letztes blog
let's rock microsoft viel spaß so und
damit befinden wir uns nun auch hier in
der extra generierten texture pack welt
nur für diese tags speck vorstellung
viele leute haben ja gesagt dass diese
map von ipod mail sei ja ist sie auch
die stand auch in der beschreibung die
könnt ihr euch auch downloaden das haben
ja viele haben gefragt was das für eine
welt ist dies von ipod mail
und die ist in der beschreibung also die
könnt ihr euch da downloaden ich habe
die nur ein bisschen konfiguriert mit
ein paar viele blöcke hier hingestellt
um das zu zeigen aber dass erst mal nur
so am rande also heute werde ich euch
das texture pack letzt vom network
minecraft vorstellen und zwar heißt
echelon texture pack und dabei trage ich
den skin von zehra kohl den habt ihr
schon in der begrüßung gesehen
ich finde ganz interessant das ist so
ein song wie skin mit einem anzug oder
irgendwie sowas also finde ich ganz
interessant den scan und ich würde sagen
wir fangen direkt hier bei den normalen
blöcken an wie zb dem wasser unter
wasser noch über wasser ist es alles ein
wenig grünlich und hellblau gehalten das
ganze text speck allgemein sind die
standard texturen nur ein paar wurden
verändert ihr seht da oben zum beispiel
die wolle die ist eigentlich genau
gleich geblieben allerdings finde ich
zum beispiel das holz ist viel besser
dass es einfach gemütlich geworden finde
ich mag solche mutigen waren wir wissen
will
und ja keine ordnung finde ich
eigentlich anständig die holzbalken
finde ich denn alle ziemlich genial aus
bis auf dass hier das weiß ich gar nicht
was das allgemein so viel holz ist aber
ich finde das holz muss nicht sein dass
ganze text beck ich weiß es
mittelalterlich gehalten aber ich find
es trotzdem ein bisschen komisch sonst
finde ich das eigentlich ziemlich hammer
die crafting tables und allgemein dieser
nutzt es findet eigentlich am aller
coolsten weil das ganze inventar hier
und es auch so wenn ich mir dass man
hier so angucke oder hier menü die
ganzen sachen finde ich sehen ziemlich
geil aus ziemlich geil
allerdings stellt keine ordnung ein paar
texturen sind auch einfach gleich
geblieben wie zum beispiel das gras aber
das glas wird zum beispiel auch
verändert connected ex-vize zeit nicht
unterstützt meinte basti glaube ich
letztens ihr bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
bla später wurden sich da haben sie sich
erlaubte dass die finde ich einfach
genial die können supergut pixeln und
das hier alles aus holz sondern als wenn
ihr sowas rausgerissen werden dass stein
so eine steinwand sage ich mal wurde die
alte muss raus kommt finde ich sehr geil
gemacht
die ganzen verschiedenen ärzte sehen
auch genial aus es ist nicht so wie bei
den normalen texturen dass da wirklich
einfach nur so was drin ist sondern dass
da auch wirklich hier so nicht nur
dieser diamant blättchen da drin sind
sondern dass die auch hier so abstreifen
sag ich mal das finde ich ganz
interessant finde ich ganz cool
allgemein wird halt alles die normalen
texturen sind das quasi einfach nur
verändert aber ich finde eigentlich ganz
gut gemacht weil es auch alles in so ein
bisschen mittelalterlichen stil gehalten
wird ich kann ich dass wir hier zeigen
solche blöcke sind eigentlich die
perfekte beispiele dafür dass das ganze
einfach ein bisschen älter gehalten ist
finde ich auf jeden fall ganz gut
gemacht bekommt von mir jetzt noch mal
kurz nach unten gehen und euch da ein
bisschen was zeigen hier wir haben hier
den den villiger der sieht fast genau
gleich aus ich glaube das deck der kopf
und ein bisschen intensiver vom kontrast
hergestellt aber sonst halt alles
ziemlich mutig ich kann noch mal ein
paar tiere spawn lassen fällt mir dazu
auf wenn wir uns wehren pixar habe ich
schon wolfe können wir auch mal meiner
eben oben rückzug dürfte der
vorbereitung maike boss so also sieht
genau gleich aus schwei sich ganz witzig
aus sieht anders aus ich glaube eine kuh
sieht auch noch anders aus moment finde
ich nur eine kommune colo colo gut da
ist ne kuh so sieht auch anders aus ich
bin grad in der snapshot version
deswegen hört ihr vielleicht ein paar
komische sounds die euch noch nicht so
bekannt sind
na ja ich würde diesem text schipek
denke ich neun von zehn diamanten geben
weil
es eigentlich eigentlich hat es zehn von
zehn diamanten verdient aber es ist
nicht ganz so mein geschmack ein paar
blöcke finde ich echt genial wie zb das
holz oder dieser ganzen crafting sachen
alles ziemlich vermutlich die mob sind
auch genial aber das glas gefällt mir
jetzt sage ich mir einfach überhaupt
nicht weil ich weiß nicht keine ahnung
ist halt nicht zu meinen geschmack und
hier diese schwerter und na ja das finde
ich ist hätten sie auch noch ein
bisschen verändern können aber im großen
und ganzen würde ich sagen 95 sagen 95
von zehn diamanten schreibt mir in die
kommentare weitere texte packs die ich
vorstellen soll oder zurzeit habe ich ja
den zebras kucera kohls ging ihr könnt
ihr auch euren scannen die kommentare
schreiben
ich würde mich über den daumen wo freuen
beim letzten video haben wir ja 500
daumen hoch geschafft vielleicht
schaffen wir dieses mal 700 daumen hoch
wird mich auf jeden fall freuen weil das
zeigt mir dass ich das richtig mache
dass euch das gefällt und dann sind wir
alle glücklich und alles ist gut und
dann würde ich sagen wenn ich raus ich
wünsche euch noch einen wundervollen tag
und bis zum nächsten mal